I think he's a win over Joshua was a
very good win with two weeks notice how
would you favor I will tie one on behind
me back and use either one just Chubby's
not right on pop-pop-pop-pop ah it eases
forever
is that a fight you're looking forward
to hey everybody welcome to a very
special episode of hotbox and I'm Evan
Britton and I'm Mike Tyson Mike we've
got the champ the champ in here Tyson
Fury with hello everybody hey Kay the
gypsy king is in the building
Oh about that gypsy lifestyle on
television my big fat gypsy this and out
of this yeah is it about that you guys
or is it about um Brad Pitt stuff from
snatch snatch movie yeah yeah that was
actually a good movie
do you that depict the gypsy culture
well not really
television they do stuff on TV to sell
of sewers so you'd never really get to
know what it was like off a TV show yeah
of course
so what's the history of the gypsy goes
back thousands of years they'd been
around since crave yeah they've been
around since Christ
they've been moving from country to
country every country go to around the
world you find gypsies they've been
around since the beginning
darn yeah beginning of time people to
come from all over the world all
different types breed seed generations
people obviously I come from England
I've been born and raised there you know
the way a lifer in digital religion what
is it it's not a religion no it's like a
culture yeah it's just sort of we
brought up the only thing we want to do
is fight which is well have become a
boxer
yeah they were named after Mike named
after Mike yes
how it happens my dad was a professional
boxer in the late eighties early
nineties heavy weight on his heroes you
really so when I was born August 12 1988
I came into the world when I was eight
weeks premature and I was I was dying I
wasn't supposed to live and when I lived
I mean dad said I want to call you after
my favorite heavyweight Tyson and the
doctor said no that's not gonna be a
good name he's not gonna be very big
disguise only weighed 1 pound him weight
I was tiny Wow and I grew up to be 6
foot 9 and 265 pounds Wow crazy you
started off back then what did that feel
like it felt really good you know I
started boxing I never hugged me first
time at you fight until I was like 16
years old
but I was brought up around box and I
was a gym rat when I my dad was going to
the gym I'd go to the gym with him and I
be hitting the bags knocking stuff over
in the gym I was brought up around it my
brothers cousins everybody boxes so we
all used to fight each other as kids
growing up and I decided I was gonna be
a heavyweight chump little world from
being a young kid when people say oh
what do you want to be when you grow up
oh I want to be whatever they wanted to
be they ask me what I want to be else a
heavyweight champion of the world enough
I wasn't gonna settle for anything else
must be such a wild journey I think
about when I was a fighter and I must
been such a wild journey fighting with
yourself yeah you know he's wondering a
guy I wanted to hope that I don't want
this guy to take my place always
wondering you know you hurt yourselves
you get a cut and you say oh I hope my
careers not over before it even starts a
lot of things there's a lot of motivate
motivating factors for you yeah we all
lose on the path to our greatness you
know and it's about overcoming and never
quitting and never giving up so fighting
is a huge part of the gypsy culture
maybe just the fighting spirit how about
you know you're not the first gypsy
heavyweight champion they must have been
gypsy bare-knuckle champion anyway to
play no wall stone a guy called gypsy
Jim mace yeah Johnny was able
first heavyweight champion on the ground
rules 1850 been like the champ
that's correct from Norfolk they called
him a swath from gypsy wow that's
amazing very good-looking though unlike
me
wellyou've there's been a lot of our
gypsy chumpies not just heavyweights
there's been middle weights or from all
over the world different white
categories well I imagine you grow up
fighting it's in your blood you're gonna
be pretty comfortable in the fight no
matter where you are whether it's a
Narang or in the street somewhere what
is the the spiritual practice or mindset
of the gypsy culture did you grow up
with with a sense of a higher power yeah
believe in God
uh-huh Christian uh-huh
and I believe that we're all here for a
reason I believe that everything I do my
life is already plumbed and set you know
this up been so many things happened to
me throughout my life and if there was
no higher power then it wouldn't be
possible for me to be even in the flight
were Wilder like brought me off the
canvas in round 12 when I was knocked
out to raise me to me feet and there to
fight on for a reason and I believe the
second return for me in boxing because
that's three year out the ring I was
dying with depression and anxiety upon
147 pounds I was taking drugs on a daily
basis I was drinking on a daily basis I
was gone I was finished the only place I
ever fought that I'd ever end up was in
a padded room somewhere it was terrible
I was thinking about suicide every day
I had nothing to be upset about I was
heavyweight champion of the world or 27
years old they had money fame glory a
family achievements kids everything
running so smooth book it didn't matter
because mental health will bring you to
your knees if you let it I was young kid
and I was fighting I was going to
everything so everything so intensifier
old [ __ ] this and that and then it's
just an illusion it didn't really matter
and I mean they really existed what was
it
Tyson that helped bring you out of that
boxing boxing brought me back because I
was living very wild and you know when
when you lose the passion to breathe
fresh air anymore and you don't want to
live you're a terrible place and I
remember a moment I was in a I was in a
high-performance car Ferrari I was
heading towards a bridge that big with a
custom-made for you know it wasn't cool
so I headed towards this bridge our
high-speed hundred ninety miles an hour
and I was gonna crash into a bridge and
before I hit this bridge I got to about
maybe five hundred fought from the
bridge and I heard a voice I physically
heard a voice speak to me and say stop
don't do this and I pulled over and I
remember I was shaking I was crying I
was thinking I knew I was totally gone I
didn't think I'd ever come back like
boxing was the last thing I ever cared
about on this position and I remember
thinking you know what if I'm ever gonna
get right again I've got to get fit I've
got to lose the weight I wasn't losing
the weight to come back to return to the
flight game I was doing that for me for
my health and the more I trained the
more I was getting better and better by
the day when I lost a lot of weight
quickly and I was I was feeling good I
was feeling great again and I wanted to
get back in the ring I felt like I had a
lot more to to offer a lot more to give
retirement wasn't for me I had three
years out the ring and it was it was a
horrible three years the worst three
years of my active life and I thought
I'm gonna get back in the ring I'm gonna
fight again and they let you keep your
title for that long yeah I had four
world titles and I they stripped me of
one within seven days and I vacated the
rest yeah vacated the reston and I came
back had a couple of easy knock over
fight
come straight back in my van Walda that
was your first fight back
Wow and that fight really I feel like
captivated the world that happy after
that really brought people back long
boxes people be happy like that people
very happy yeah it was so exciting
you know to see two titans back in the
rain clash and like that you know at
that time it was a breath of fresh air
because there was an evii way in England
called Joshua where he was a world
champion and he was unbeaten and wild
was over here he was in the UK and he
was talking back and forth for like over
a year like [ __ ] they didn't want to
fight each other so I think it was more
Joshua didn't want to fight wild ever
rather than ever way around so I thought
you know what I'm gonna fight give me
the fight so they looked at me and II
thought this guy's finished he can't
fight no more how can you lose all that
weight and I've all that time out the
ring abusing your body and then come
back to this level but maybe I was
finished in my body but my mindset was
that strong and I believed that I was
gonna win but if you believe it first
with the mind anything is achievable
angry and I believed it so much I don't
never ever doubt myself in a fight no
matter who is with who I always believe
I'm gonna win somehow someway I'll find
a way and we put on a great fight and
you know people are looking forward to
the year - pretty much yeah hell yeah is
that in the books Yeah right about
before you fail do we match yeah I'm
fighting on September the 14th in Vegas
gonna get some Swedish guy called Auto
wallet he's had number four ranked WBA
unbeaten in twenty five six six southpaw
so he might take a couple of rounds to
get him out what's up Mike
hey Evan did you read that book the
House of Rothschild mm ah I gave you the
book three you know between my two hour
drive to and from work my family trying
to get my workouts in I just don't have
time to read a book right now brother
no audible or doable you can do while
you're cleaning a house working your
teeth taking a bath it's consoling me
any place anywhere all over the world
information fluid information audible
look at you you're a genius
I wish I made it at audible for
audiobooks duh I could do it anytime
anywhere
audible anytime anywhere start listening
today with a 30 day audible trial choose
one audiobook and two audible originals
absolutely free visit audible.com slash
hotboxing that's hotboxing h OT b o x i
n or you can use your phone and text
hotboxing - 500 500 that's right just
use your phone to text hotboxing h OT b
o x IM - 5 0 0 5 0 0
so at 27 you're 30 now 20,000 31 that he
won well no time for the same age that's
amazing so at 27 you're a world champion
and that was the pinnacle that was the
peak of the mountain that your whole
life you had been striving to get to
right what was it in that that you were
you felt as though you weren't being
fulfilled you know I suppose I suffered
with depression and anxiety my whole
life from being a little boy to being a
man but I always had a goal would become
in every way champion of the world and
he always brought me back out of the
darkness to achieve that goal and
nothing else mattered a lot of tragedy
go on in me life a lot of stuff happened
that maybe could have put me off track
of being everywhere jumbo I always sort
of sidetracked all of that and
concentrated on the job in hunt and when
they said right you you're gonna fight
Klitschko for the for the World
Championship I was like when I win I'm
not gonna have a goal anymore so I
almost knew going into the fight that I
was going to calm down it was going to
be a disaster I was very depressed going
into the fight going into training camps
I knew I was going to beat this guy and
I said to I remember saying to me Timmy
Darden me brother said win lose or draw
us that I probably won't fight again
after this boxed all your life to get to
this position and you're gonna just walk
away I was like you know what I'm not
feeling any more book I looked back in
it now when I was very ill going into
that fight I wasn't well minded goes in
there beats him for five minutes I was
happy and then when I got back to
changer in my voice I said
I've won 5 World title belts I beat the
second longest reigning heavyweight
champion in history
what next I don't have a purpose anymore
finish is weird make a little kid and I
won the title after I fell in love with
that illusion of myself and [ __ ] really
hell [ __ ] and you're like let me conquer
more anymore about me let me have the
best girl in the world and we have the
best seat in the [ __ ] restaurant
give me the best [ __ ] car what the
best plan I was [ __ ] all so
self-absorbed you know I mean I couldn't
[ __ ] enough girls couldn't have enough
fight and have enough fights outside the
ring it's yeah it wasn't enough yeah
it's so interesting because I very much
relate to what you're saying you know
yeah that feeling of what's next this is
it this is everything I've I've every
bit of my life that I've dedicated to
achieving this thing and I did it now
what the [ __ ] life but that's just my
negative outlet right that's because we
don't have no I was looking so fluff
yeah back then we you know have no self
loathing it's so easy to say that's it
you have self love you find so many
increment things to do to so you know I
played football for everyone but me I
played football to prove everybody wrong
to show everybody how powerful and
dominant and scary I was I played
football to destroy other people to
inflict my pain on others and I never
once was playing it just because I loved
it
you know and that's a much more
sustainable source of power out of a
fleet that thinner just after the people
in general with Jostein that because
this is our acceptance you know then I
gotta give you the same acceptance if
you're not playing at a team then if you
just retired player and the different
kind of acceptance yeah I'm not gonna
get the same [ __ ] girlfriend you did
and the [ __ ] bass football player do
you within a retired play is all about
continuing to do this stuff and this is
our rice we do this to we can't do it
anymore
yeah becomes our identity yeah and we
can't even help it we gotta go to I go
to a school to learn how to get out of
that she'll of us off that mask of our
identity yeah yeah it's very true and it
sounds like in those three years out and
then finding that passion again you
tapped into something a little deeper
and yourself 100% you know the first
time I was boxing first career I call it
two careers the first time was about
achieving my dreams becoming everywhere
in the world and all that sort stuff we
just talked about all that power and
what if and all this stuff but when I
got there I fought like this is a lot of
[ __ ] it wasn't what I expected and from
England's definitely because England
they look at back to the photos from a
total different different perspective
they're like gods out there so how do
you how do you live their life in
England you can't go nowhere
exactly I know he can't go no way yeah I
can't go because they're waiting for you
yeah yeah you hang out here to be 40,000
people waiting for you in England they
don't [ __ ] around
that's crazy what they're fighters
they're soccer players and stuff they
will be played over there with you a
hundred percent how many people where
did you fight you for him in America
right that they were yeah how many how
many arm people from the UK came over
about seven thousand yeah there was a
lot of British fans traveled but like
the second career it's not about winning
belts or anything I've just having fun
you know a box now
because I love to fight and I finally
found what I love to do were there and
that's to be be involved in in good
fights and um take punches and hit
people back you know I'd go into these
fights and I don't give a [ __ ] you know
I'd like a loose cannon the crazy
character
I don't carefully hit me I don't care
what they do I'm gonna enjoy myself I'm
gonna I'm falling the fight they're all
serious like oh my god it's a fight ah
I'm like doing dances waving my arms and
yes singing to him I noticed that care
anymore you know I've gone past the
stage of caring about fighting who was
your last fight I boxed in Vegas oh yeah
in June 15 my boxer German guy called
Tom Schwartz that's right and I watched
all of that pre fight stuff man and your
energy was unbelievable if you were
smiling yeah you were putting on a show
we're in the entertainment business yeah
I was in Las Vegas I was there to pawn
the show I did that won the fight no to
the next one yeah you know I'm not even
fun I've never been as happy as this in
my whole career that's never I'm so
happy right now so mentally well so
unconcerned about what people think of
maybe Ruiz I think he's a win over
Joshua was a very good win on two weeks
notice how would you favor I would tie
one behind me back and use either one
just jab he's not right up
pop-pop-pop-pop ah
hopefully this fight ever
[Laughter]
is that affair you're looking forward to
I'm gonna fight this guy on the 14th and
then we're gonna go for the wild a
rematch February 22nd nice and then this
time I'm not gonna leave it to the
judges it's gonna go over within four or
five rounds then we're gonna move on to
fight anybody that you're going for you
thought somebody else yeah he fought one
fight before Hey he fought Dominic
preserve one round one round knockout
and he's like Louis Ortiz in his next
fight so how do we met yeah yeah I think
now go quicker this time now Luis Ortiz
is 147 years old you know how old he is
Cuba they they fight forever
just keep doing em to fight with Tyson
what do you think about like back in the
day Mike had 15 fights in a year or
before that Sugar Ray Robinson had like
a hundred fights in a year and now how
many fights you have in a year maybe
three that's crazy it is crazy but when
you started off at the beginning you can
have all these fights I in my first year
as a professional I had nine fights and
then the more you step up the more the
fights become less they need more time
to build them more time to sell them I
wish I could fight ten times here once a
month would be good yeah I offered to do
a bomber month campaign like Joe Louis
unless you do specific and possibility
of them getting hurt anymore
I'd love to keep very active like if I
can get three fights yeah I think that's
me being very active I have a lot of
time inactive yeah like one fight per
year one fight in three years just
craziness seems like you get out of
rhythm much you become much fit and then
you lose it all yeah and you become
skiing and you didn't have a couple of
fights to get back while you was yeah so
is it a matter of them promoting the
fights like who's your contract with as
a boxer is it with the promoter or is it
with like is that is it with a league no
it could be with the hotel the hotel
hotel it could be with the television
station clowny interesting oh so like
you have a contract with Showtime to
fight certain amount of time for a
certain amount of money a year
interesting its way then the fact that
they will pay him well if he's in the
West Coast like a casino or something
the casino mostly in the West Coast like
Vegas will pay him a certain amount of
money in the fight a certain amount of
time at their hotel you know and so the
casinos has really been kicking like the
East Coast
auditoriums in the but because we're
paying you to comfort in our auditorium
well you got to pay these big
auditorium the fight in the arena so you
know it's really a no-brainer what are
the big casinos MGM grabs yeah yeah
that's just one that I'm through uh
dozens of them now yeah yeah you know I
fought lost fight at the MGM Grand
okay where's this fight coming up this
fights not a new new arena in Vegas
called the t-mobile Center okay a new
one year for it's like a twenty thousand
seat awesome
that'll be cool how are you dealing with
you know your success and continuing to
build yourself up and your new career
like I said I don't see a success I
don't see it's anything I just live day
to day you know what when you're like me
I could be happy now I'm suicidal in the
evening uh-huh yeah so when you live
like that or your medication no my
medication is training no I think you
fail every bar the drugs test in the
world then yeah I just I train I took my
medicine is as become training I used to
like just train for a fight go out a
camp and pot on or turn away not train
just eat [ __ ] all the time drink a lot
and on the second time I'm coming back
like I'm staying in shape the whole time
I'm training every day for me not just
for a sport for me to keep myself
mentally well and strong and the
training camps and lifestyle of our
boxer has become very easy for me now
sour box up 265 pounds and walk around
at 265 pounds where before I was walking
around at 370 pounds or more forums
reduces to 370 I would never stay in
shape um in all seasons if I don't have
a fight like when I stopped fighting
three and four times a year like where I
was just boom is fighting our trainer my
disco Gordian and drinking yeah [ __ ]
then we have to fight argue people being
my room we finally get these just a new
deathless de no it's all it's really a
form of that's how you understand self
care at that time you're like this is
taking care of myself because now I got
to just rest and recover and replenish
and Gorge myself that's just I didn't
have and then have good um life skills
back then yeah that's what I'm saying
that was waiting saw my brain should be
it's a staying shake yeah
keep running down don't don't go to the
gym you just keep running everyday
just keep your Cardinal yeah keep the
cardio up yeah so you know when you was
doing all this [ __ ] all the time
did you catch many diseases that's part
of being the guy that gets all the girls
to if you that guys [ __ ] everybody
that comes with a tote yeah Oh
I was recently over in Spain and someone
said oh no don't [ __ ] doc girl she's got
herpes I said well she [ __ ] me she
could have chlamydia gonorrhea
everything else
oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
I caught a kissing disease one day my
mom what is this my bot oh yeah my
[ __ ] um the lymph nodes yeah yeah
he's [ __ ] glance Pole well duh oh I
look like a [ __ ] toad a toad
he has big glands yeah Wow you can't
believe I feel like I was dying
really oh your pain like no other you
don't believe it so much pain are you
sure that was some kiss and I'm not
[ __ ] like it that - it goes both where
you get it both ways turn the [ __ ]
needle going in your ass snaps our
pillow thing penicillin yeah thankfully
I've never contracted lucked out till
you gave me brother's assistant yeah I
got a I got four brothers no sisters
yeah a five brothers knows his stuff -
Wow yeah Rio's fighting all the time all
the time yeah
may my younger brother we used to fight
every day all the time and I've got
younger brother again he was also a
professional fighter yeah yeah I think
he had nine pro fights yeah but he had a
bad eye so he had to retire from boxing
he would have been good he was her she
was sharp compact and powerful hmm heavy
weight heavy weight yeah how tall he was
about six foot six four six four and two
hundred and fifty pounds huh yeah stark
you you have a family yeah I got a wife
on five kids five kids five kids that I
do
Ramos whatever you're having for 10 10
kids yeah you gotta work hard on dripper
son
gotta keep it going
Tennyson what are you there's a lot to
live in England in England right yeah um
the cost of living hi there yeah it's
expensive yeah I would think so yeah
anybody lived it [ __ ] live over there
mean you gotta get it together it's
really expensive yeah I think I think
America's expensive those well really
think so yeah
Wow some cities yeah you think so don't
you see the tax game over there the
monster man really over there you get
50% tax and 20% of all us 70% of the
money gone yeah that's [ __ ] but once
you pay the taxes you're cool they don't
take no other stuff out yeah paid over
here to attach you for everything on
thank you for your clothing oh thank you
for that bag you don't pay taxes on food
and no things like Oh free you see a
price and then you go to the till and
they want tax on top of them yeah our
home is all included uh-huh so you take
it out when they give you the check
interesting I guess that's a good
trade-off how do you feel about it you
know it's one of those things is what it
is we're all guaranteed two things in
life death and taxes no but listen it
can't escape any of them you have to
look from this perspective though even
though all the billionaires there's more
billionaires coming out of England and
moving England any place in the world I
don't knows why England if they're so
worried about their taxes there has to
be some kind of tax loophole where then
that threatened like they are over here
I'm sure there are loopholes no doubt
about it could everybody's gonna England
rich people really know how to maneuver
and navigate the taxes it's not you'd
have to be rich you just have to be
educated we pay taxes yeah yeah it's
[ __ ]
still I suppose he pay a high tax
bracket to live in a safe place
yeah you know imagine if you lived in a
third world country and you getting
stabbed and killed every second on your
doorstep yeah but you're not paying
taxes hmm so over there it's clean place
to live quite safe
spot it really it's great what are you
doing in LA I'm here in LA we've got
some press for the fight go to ESPN
studios in a bit awesome - bit there and
few more interviews and things just to
promote the fight for September 14th but
turn in a movie and do yeah oh yeah
you'd be great go down the street over
there and go I'm gonna sit hang out they
would love to hang out with you mr. ed
down the street no we're just gonna go
back in there do the ocean oh yeah I'll
call that down the street yeah yeah do
you have any interest in that acting
no not really well to be fair
Hal girl never know what the future also
overly if it was a porn and pornographic
movie what do you see for life after
boxing or even thinking that far yeah I
wanted you off the box you know one day
where I want to start a heavyweight
fight Factory hmm I'm bringing
heavyweights from all over the world if
I'm in in one facility sharpen in each
of a rope and try and take him further
anyway champions I love that have you a
training ground basically have to wait
braiding ground I love that it's awesome
it was a young fighter what is your what
are your options how do you how do you
get in you just have to find a gym and
you know you work with all the other
fighters is that the best best situation
suppose oh yeah I get to a gym that I am
I just people discovered me they
wandered in box I want you to box or
something how did that happen yeah how
did it well you grew up in it
I grew up around boxes we are very easy
for me to get involved in it yeah I'm of
England being a small place small
country yeah it's like if you any good
at all and you're gonna be selected to
box for for the country and in
tournaments all over the world yeah so
yeah I used to walk to the gym everyday
though my little brother I used to jog
there he used to ride a bike nice train
two hours three hours and run back it's
awesome but without them opportunities
to do that then I maybe wouldn't even be
here today who knows so that's another
thing I would like to do open up a
amateur boxing club to give other people
opportunity society my life
it's definitely needed absolutely if I
had to pay the be a box I wouldn't never
been a box I had no money
yeah alone free had a box yeah I mean
that's
I'm sure there's millions of kids who
would love that opportunity you know
have somewhere to go get instructed or
be like a family if you want you go
family in that family life and everybody
knows what you're doing everybody got
the eye open got the friend the family
got the isle he's involved with the gym
he's one of the boys look out for him it
was just incredible lifestyle yeah Tyson
is there anything you any questions you
have for Mike is you prepped for this
next fight not really you know no not
really I don't know if many questions
yeah that's good I mean that's a good
place to be is there anything you're
curious about Mike and his new life
after boxing when the life is pretty
interesting
understandable yeah go for it yeah it's
near life of yours it's giving you a new
lease of life yeah thank God cuz my
laughs my last [ __ ] life with whoa I
don't know how this should happen me but
without all luck catastrophic action
would you be the same man you are today
without the experience well I needed
that experience you're a living legend
I'm sorry with a living legend yeah well
miss cool
living I can't believe I wanted to die
some so often when I was younger I think
I hate living I get 53 I love living I
don't wanna [ __ ] die I hate the fact
that I gotta die now the living is so
interesting it is every day is what's
the motivation right now excuse me
what's the motivation yes for me if the
absorbed my existence you know and
realize that life is a joke I took it to
Syria wonderful son you know I don't
know not long after this I'll die soon
and I won't exist anymore and I'm and
then I have to go to the other one I
want to see what that's like I can't
believe this energy that I have just
died than it doesn't exist I mean I live
here no more but I have to go somewhere
hundred percent you know and that's what
I'm looking forward to now not for a
long time yet whatever happens it
happens I'm just looking forward cuz
life is grateful death has to be just as
great as life you see I think the worst
the worst the worst day of my life right
it's my mother of my children dying the
world the worst day of my life besides
that incident that happened that could
happen to anybody my probably happen to
everybody all over the world at that
time life is still beautiful what stay
in life is still beautiful day if I
don't take internalize in all over these
me and my mother died about baby died
why me if I don't look at it from that
perspective life was always beautiful
every day was beautiful you know life is
precious and it's beautiful just to wake
up in the morning before before I used
to take it all for granted I didn't care
and care about nothing I didn't care
about family friends relatives
achievements I didn't care about for
call I just just didn't care but now
after going to hell I'm back I
appreciate fresh air and a glass of
water creates smaller things in life
because when you've lost you never know
what you've really got until it's gone
yeah but I've had the opportunity to be
shot down and come back you know and you
really find out who your friends are
who the people are really behind you who
leaves who jumps often and everybody
just loves a winner
nobody wants to be around the loser
nobody wants to be around the man who's
lost his mind so you really find out who
your friends are
the people who call you and distress
when you're down and you're out you
don't have any more to offer to them so
I suppose I got to see that side of
everything without being beaten in a
boxing ring first so then on the
comeback I have the smallest team ever
the people who were there for me when I
was gone when I was out so yeah I keep
it nice and small happy for every day
and whatever happens in life happens
okay we have to understand that being
afraid of the being entertainer if
anything it's being in the light that we
have to understand that this is will be
over soon this is not gonna last forever
so why the why at this moment wow it's
an enormous and it's profitable I have
to make the best I can out of it that's
what this is all about now with him he
has to make the best possible move the
future right now while you can
yeah it's interesting hearing you say
cuz I know this as well as that before
you said you didn't give a [ __ ] about
anything and now you don't care but in a
different way it's like you're detached
with love from it all you know and I
think that's an important issue that's a
that's a difference you know but it's
interesting because it's the flip side
of the same coin hmm you know going from
a place of not caring about anything in
your life in a destructive way and then
coming to a place where you cannot care
about anything in life because you're
not attached to anything or any specific
outcome or how anything is supposed to
be your look you know before I used to
take everything and think oh I want this
and whatnot I was never happy with what
I got human nature we always want more
yeah no matter what it is no matter how
much you've got of something then you
always searching for more things I think
that's ego nature no doubt about it
that's the nature of the ego I know it's
like I don't care for that if I lose
everything I don't care what happens
nothing really is ours anyway in life
wanna borrow it until he died and it all
goes yeah the only thing we truly own in
this life is moments in time this is a
moment in time for me that will never be
erased
I'm the mother what up and this is
always gonna be my time this will be my
moment time because I lived here and I
was a parlous yeah you know everything
else this bag this watch these clothes
they'll all go through what does it
really matter
yeah yeah your body will go this is a
shell yeah but what's inside hope to god
lives on forever it definitely does
you know maybe maybe I'm maybe not
living on fair that's cool too
yeah you know we all know that yeah
maybe just maybe it's stop here in our
[ __ ] selves and talking about some
thinking about ourselves in our mind
sometimes yeah you know I mean maybe
that's cool not to stop that that's
bliss yeah this have no thoughts yeah
you know but like you said before why
are we here well you have all these
experiences and then what would just
switch yourself after you close your
eyes it can't be possible
yeah well that's the ultimate question
isn't it what happens when you die I
reckon we wake up with it all a dream
youth wake up what do you think Tyson
well like I said before I'm a practicing
Christian her and the Bible says when
you die all the answers will be revealed
and everything will be like almost in HD
and everything you wanted to know in
your life will be answered but they also
says that we'll be accountable for every
action we did so I don't know I I just
don't think I think um
even as a Muslim a formal Christian I
just believe that um when I took the
Tories believe there's no good and no
bad there's no right and no wrong
you know I mean who are we sir we're not
our brain is not even at the height of
this development we're not developed
really enough to understand why we did
something right or wrong we don't
understand our selfishness our greed our
ego we don't understand and we can't
comprehend it we can't even conceive it
to another human being what is really
when its operating we're nothing who are
we we can't explain ourselves what am i
doing here what the [ __ ] am i doing I
already know I should be scared
I don't know me I don't know you don't
know what the [ __ ] are we
I just know my mind tell me everything
is my mind is just not reliable most of
the time yeah especially when you've
been indoctrinated with all of the
materiality of life and modern culture
that you know you have to break out of
that show I mean really at the end of
the day our experiences and who we
project into the world is just like
everything that's going on and here all
our relationships that we have with
everyone around us all the things all
the attachments we have are about what's
going on inside it has gone yeah if I
actually has God always been here to
somebody Creek on how did God come to
existence
good question somebody say there's
something that something I had greater
than me I had to worship it and then I
call it God there what is consciousness
a witness or something that we don't see
you know but we definitely should this
is it this is where you have to be for
now at least yeah I like the idea of you
know when you die all the all the
questions you have in life are answered
you know it I believe that's part of the
deal for sure the accountability thing I
believe in that to an extent of you know
I think God is all forgiving and all
accepting and you know at the end of the
day it really comes down to your
perception of yourself and your own
ability to forgive yourself you know
that's the ultimate test yeah
because there were the hardest on
ourselves of anyone there's no one I
mean there's no one else no there's no
one here
inflicting little angry because we don't
have to have his pretty much yeah and we
want to know everything we are we based
our acceptance on knowing stuff too
being smart you know when you hurt
someone you know when you inflict damage
you cause wreckage you cause pain you
know what that is and there's no one
there to fix that but you you know you
know how that feels I know how it feels
you know and at the end of the day it
all comes down to how do I feel about
myself you know no matter what you do in
your life though yeah all comes down to
you whether you're a successful athlete
whether you're a visitor whether you've
got a regular nine-to-five job the
biggest thing in the world is
contentment yeah who you are and what
you are I know plenty of rich people are
no billionaires and a no millionaires
and 99.9% of them ain't happy very
unhappy people yes but then I know
people who work 95 for minimum wages and
are so positive and so happy that
there's a rule though the ball so don't
ain't they in a bad position and
everybody else who's like super rich or
whatever because they're helping
contending with our life and their
surroundings
and everybody in it some people are not
meant to consent concert had to grab
that concept of happiness hmm
why do I have to search for happiness is
too it's too difficult to search for it
you know too complex Europe you know I
mean it's the moment happiness is
moments nobody could have a whole hour
of happiness Oh take a whole lifetime
King years of happiness yeah how did I
mean it's consistently happy it's a 10
years there's not a tenth of a second of
miserable you know where they're going
with their a hell of a per the guy
that's not real I know I've been posting
a lot of this positive [ __ ] on my
Instagram because I don't know what else
to do with social media other than put
positive [ __ ] out there you know and
sometimes it comes off I share my own
experiences and people go like oh I'm
sorry you're feeling down today or
you're feeling angry today and I'm like
I'm not [ __ ] angry dude and I'm not
feeling down those feelings and emotions
come up yes but life is not about being
happy and [ __ ] excited all the time
you know we're on a [ __ ] wave of
emotions that's constantly moving and
flowing and just because you're up one
minute doesn't mean life is great and
just because you're down the next
doesn't mean life is [ __ ] you know you
got to be fun full for old moment
exactly what I'm pounds like months all
there it's all a blessing it's all a
blessing
it's just our perception any times I
went clean now and we know and I feel my
thumb I'm clear I'm feeling perfectly
I'm working out I'm even good
everything's good never got feet now
what's gonna cook what's gonna happen to
me relapse what's gonna happen to make
me want to get do some cocaine what's
gonna what can happen cuz I feel like
I'm invincible now so what does it get
what is it could happen to make me do
that yeah you know I mean yeah and why
am I even thinking about something would
make me do that because that's one of my
biggest fears getting high again going
out and [ __ ] with people you know
you know put my life in some stranger's
hands uh that's the fucked-up place
where we've all been you know my biggest
fear like you just said Mike is going
back to drugs back to cocaine I don't
know that I can never go back there yeah
I've got an addictive personality if I'm
doing anything I'll do it [ __ ]
hundred percent I'm so I'm so control it
controls me somewhere it's really liquor
perhaps I won't say I'm an alcoholic
I say I'm a drug addict I mean if I'm
everything else but I have to feel in my
sick man I'm too proud to be an
alcoholic but I'm a big alcoholic but in
my mind I don't want to say that I'd
rather be the drug it's cooler to be the
cocaine I don't tell anybody I'm
alcoholic I'm not a devil for the drink
yeah yeah I'm a bear about to be an
alcoholic well you know those are such
it's such interesting labels because
alcohol is really it's just the
substance you use to fill the hole and
it does a damn good job love it doesn't
know what it does [ __ ] yeah
you know it's interesting to me the
labels that be get put on because it's
really an emotional sickness you know
it's a it's a sickness of the mind a
spirituality spirituality
it's a spiritual sickness note that
about you know and that just happens to
be the thing that in this dimension we
can take to to make it all go away for a
moment but I will say this alcohol and
drugs if you're if you've suffering with
mental health problems yeah it makes it
go away for like five minutes
yeah but when you wake up the next day
crash without even more the tsunami
never do it again and later and then
they disappear what is this thing ever
yeah if alcohol was invented today be
class a drug for sure definitely Mike
said this before and it's totally true
you know you put a few guys in a room
and a bottle
vodka a few hours later they're in a
fistfight yeah Kelly Taylor never laid
it - they're gonna kill each other yeah
it's just amazing what alcohol can do
you smoke a joint with five or six
people eat hug it I'll show what are
your feelings on cannabis do you stay
completely away or you completely sober
these days yeah oh yeah I've never been
a weed smoker to be honest okay have you
dabbled in CBD
no no valence psychoactive no I've never
never the only drug wolf my choice was
cocaine oh good
yeah the co needles I'll give me life so
you're like 370 doing coke 20 doing coke
you should be happy your heart damn bus
exactly I think it nearly did you know I
was on the verge of having a heart
attack I couldn't bend down and tie my
shoelaces up about being out of breath I
was look in the mirror thing what a
state such a shudder from your former
glory only a few years ago what ever
happened to you and cocaine for while
you live in a life and you pass a mirror
you're looking whoa the reality sets a
little [ __ ] that no good clean life
is the best your face is puffy you got
sores in your nose and your lips and
[ __ ] my lips and my nose and lip you
look like a [ __ ] I look like a
leopard okay I hope he blisters all over
my [ __ ] face when I do [ __ ] coke
off Oh [ __ ] blisters I look like a
[ __ ] disease infested [ __ ] vomit
[Laughter]
god bless you guys god bless us all for
you know being clean and sober minded
you know Tyson man thank you so much for
coming thank you cell phone traffic me
absolute pleasure it's been my pleasure
to have you here Mike great episode yes
after that we got the champ of the
champion okay deep we went real deep
you're welcome back anytime anytime
please awesome segment yeah good luck in
your next fight
thank you very much do you wanna let
anybody let everybody know where they
can find you and follow you yeah i'm on
instagram gipsy.king 101 i'm
choy - Tyson underscore theory awesome
awesome you heard it everybody hey
that's it for this episode of hot boxing
be sure to subscribe to our YouTube
channel hot boxing Mike Tyson Harris
check out our website hot box in
podcast.com until next time I'm Evan
Britain and Mike Tyson and I'm the Gypsy
cake gypsy king and we're out of here
everybody bye guys
[Music]